في اخر ايام الهدنه الجيش السوداني يكثف
هجماته على الدعم السريع للتقدم نحو القصر
الجمهوري
الهلال الاحمر السوداني يؤكد انهيار
البنيه الصحيه في غرب دارفور بسبب مواجهات
الجيش ودار السريع
مبعوث الامم للشؤون الانسانيه يحذروا من
تدهور الاوضاع الانسانيه في السودان جراء
المواجهات المستمره
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
الاسطول الخامس الامريكي يعلن اعتراض
الحرس الثوري الايراني لناقله نفط في
مضيقه هرمز
[موسيقى]
طبعا كل المراكز المعطله بحاجه الحرب
نعمل في هذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم
امكانيات اللي ما موجوده
بعض الادويه والمعدات
كان تقريبا طلعت ما فيش ولا ركشه ولا
مواصله والسيارات تصل بتعدي فش حدا بيوقف
لك وكان ورا البيت فيه زي في المنطقه
الصناعيه محروقه فكان لسه الدخان شغال
فيعني عن جد حسيت انه يعني رعب هو كان في
شعور يعني خوف
ورعب يعني انك تشوف جوتك مرميه يمين يسار
وناس مقطعه
والبنوك محروقه يعني بتحسي انه خلاص بطل
في امان نهائي ومستقبل الوقف
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل العربيه بتجدد الاشتباكات رغم
الهدنه السادسه المعلنه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع واضاف المراسل ان ذوي الانفجارات
سمع فيها الخرطوم واندرمان ورصد المراسل
تحريقا لطائرات الجيش السوداني في سماء
العاصمه حيث استهدفت تمركزات تابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع في المقابل ردت قوه الدعم
السريع بمضادات ارضيه في محيط القصر
الرئاسي
اذا نتابع معكم هذه الصور من وسط العاصمه
السودانيه حيث ما زالت اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد لا تفيد الانباء وفقا لمراسل
العربيه بشبكات بين قوات الاحتياط المركزي
والدعم قرب القصر الجمهوري بالخرطوم وفق
المعطيات التي تحدثت عنها بعض البيانات
المراقبه للوضع العسكري والميداني تتحدث
عن اعاده تمركز لقوات الدعم السريعه في
الاحياء في وسط العاصمه السودانيه بالتالي
حصلت اشتباكات منذ الصباح هذا اليوم منذ
الساعات الاولى من هذا الصباح سمع ذوي
قذائف وايضا شوهدت الطائرات الحربيه تحلق
في سماء المدينه وتقصف بعضا من المراكز
والاهداف بالتالي كان هناك رد من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع بمضادات الطيران الان ايضا
يسمع عن اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله في
العاصمه الخرطوم وايضا في ام درمان رغم
الهدنه المعلنه نتابع معكم هذه الصور رغم
ان هذا الدخان المتصاعد في سماء المدينه
ولكنه الا انه ليس بالكثيف حتى هذه اللحظه
لكن الانباء تفيد عن اشتباكات بالاسلحه
ثقيله في الخرطوم وان درمان رغم الهدنه
وهذه للشبكات من قوات الاحتياط المركزي
ودعم السريع قرب القصر الجمهوري بالخرطوم
تحديدا
[موسيقى]
هذا ونشر الجيش صورا لضبط مخازن اسلحه قال
انها تابعه لقوات دعم السريع حيث تحتوي
على الاف الذخائر
خاصه بالدعم السريع تركوها واللوحه
تحت الجو المخازن الارضيه تحت الجبل
الجواز
مخزن عملاق مخزن كبير جدا جدا
من الذخائر
في اخرها بيان للجيش حمل قوات الدعم
السريع المسؤوليه لخارق الهدنه في الاحياء
السكنيه البيان اشار الى وقوع اعمالناب
للبنوك والمحلات التجاريه في محيط الساده
الهلال باندرمان لافتا الى هروب اعداد
كبيره من قوات الدعم السريع من اندرمان
باتجاه الغرب وقال الجيش ان سفير الهند في
الخرطوم ابلغ عن اقتحام السفاره وسرقه
ممتلكاتها
رغم اعلان الجنوب السودان موافقه اطراف
الصراع في السودان على وقف اطلاقنا لمده
اسبوع اعتبارا من يوم غد الخميس قال يوسف
عزت مستشار حميتي قال للعربيه ان قوات
الدعم السريع لم توافق بعد على الهدنه كما
اكد انهم لا يرفضون الهدن في حال ضمان
الالتزام بها متهم
لم يستطع البرهان
الوفاء بسته هدى وما زلنا نحن اليوم نعيش
هدنه معلنه
والطيران يخطف المدنيين ويخطف مواقعنا
لم يتم الالتزام بكل هذه الهدن فمن السابق
لاوانه
النقد الحوت لمده اسبوع تبدا بعد نهايه
هذه الهدنه نحن نتعامل مع قوه
وافقنا على هدى بواسطه امريكا بواسطه
السعوديه لم يتم الالتزام بالهدنه
ليس لجهات ما تقول من خلق الهدنه
هذا وضعها عدد من المواطنين بجنوب دارفور
دعوه طرفي نزاع في السودان الى ضروره وقف
الحرب والاقتتال مشرين ان الصراع خلف
اثارا اقتصاديه كبيره منها الركود في
السلع وارتفاع الاسعار والله يا اخي نتمنى
من الحكومه يعني توافقوا ويتفقوا
ويتعاونوا واحنا كلنا سودانيين مع ان
الفرق بين احمر اصفر اخضر
الدعم السريع ابناءنا ما في حاجه داخل
السكر
في امان في الاحياء
ما في اي شيء حاصل لما نرجع للعلاج الليله
العلاج
الليله ممكن تكسروا النص انتم بتغيروا
يا جماعه الى 80 والزيت من من 25 الى 35
وكل بعد دقيقه بيزيد كل المواطنين يا
جماعه انه السوق ده من بكره وبعد بكره
وقدام البنوك هتفتح واي زول يا جماعه يفتح
دكانه وما يتخوفوا نسال الله ان يوحدنا
سبحانه وتعالى اولا الوحده كل الناس يعني
توحد عشان تصل لبره الامان باذن الله
سبحانه وتعالى
في السودان الاشتباكات تتواصل رغم الهدن
وضع انساني كارثي وتحذيرات دوليه من
الاسواق اما شرطه السودانيه باتت امام حد
اخر سببه التفلت الامني في البلاد اذ نظمت
حملات لمحاربه الجريمه بهدف بسط هيبه
الدوله وسياده حكم القانون الحملات شملت
في يومها الاول مناطق الفتاح العضليين
وسوق الدخينات وسوق الكلاكله اللفه مرورا
بابو ادم والعزوزاب وسوق الشجره بينما
نظمت الحمله في يومها الثاني في شارع
الشهيد ابراهيم شمس الدين ومنطقه السوق
الشعبي بالخرطوم وابو حمامه والمرافق
الحيويه اما حمله اليوم الثالث شملت مناطق
امتداد شارع الرميله مرورا بصك العمله
ومخازن السكر والمنطقه الصناعيه
الحملات حققت اهدافها المطلوبه بمشاركه
القوات المسلحه لتامين الاسواق والمناطق
التجاريه الهامه والمرافق الحيويه
لمعايره الوضع على الارض نذهب الى
الصحفيين من هناك معنى من اندرمان صحفي في
مكتب العربيه في السودان شهدي نادر اهلا
بك معنا في هذه التغطيه على العربيه بدايه
هل تجددت الاشتباكات في ام درمان رغم
الهدنه المعلنه
مرحبا نعم التجدد الاشتباكات اصوات
الطيران الحربي منذ صباح هذا اليوم في عده
هاي اتجاهات في جنوب مدينه درمان وكذلك في
شرقها بحسب افاده شاهد عيان فان مغضوب سقط
على احد الله المنازل في مدينه ابروف
شرقي مدينه ام درمان لم تسجل اصابات كذلك
علمنا بان اشتباكات في منطقه شرق النيل
شرق العاصمه الخرطوم وكذلك في منطقه وسط
الخرطوم حيث دارت اشتباكات هناك وتحديدا
في منطقه السوق العربي المنطقه هي منطقه
شهيره ظلت محل مناوشات واشتباكات بشكل
مستمر هذه هي المجمر الاوضاع اليوم
والهدوء الحضري يخيم على على المدينه
المواطنين هناك ثم حركه هي بدات منذ عده
ايام انا الان اتواجد داخل احدى
المستشفيات هي مستشفى خاص كان يقدم
علاج في مختلف التخصصات من بينها الجراحه
والاسنان وخلافه منذ هذه الاحداث تحولت
تحول الى امراض النساء والتوليد يقيم
عمليات الولاده القيصريه ويشرف على امراض
النساء والتوليد مرعي مدير المدير بشكل
مجاني بحسب ما علمت منذ بدايه هذه هذه
الاحداث في اطار تعاون ما بينه وما بين
جمعيه اطباء سودانيين في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه معي الان لو كان وقتك يسمح
الدكتور محمد فتحي الرحمن مدير عام
المستشفى
تفضل دكتور
مرحب بك كيف الحال الحمد لله
كم الحالات التي استقبلها المستشفى فيما
يخص امراض النساء والتوليد بدايته طيب
بدايه حتى هذه اللحظه عدد العمليات
القيصريه التي تمت في المستشفى منذ بدايه
الاحداث حوالي 200 عمليه وعدد العمليات
الولادات الطبيعيه بحوالي 300 بلاده
طبيعيه هل بشكل مجاني هذه العمليات بشكل
مجاني كامل ام ان هناك رسوم يتم استقطاع
طبعا دي كانت كلها في اطار تعاون بيننا
وبين جمعيه سابر هي جمعيه الاطباء
السودانيين بامريكا في بدايه الاسبوع
الاول كانت العمليات تتم بشكل مجاني تماما
بعد نهايه الاسبوع الاول نظرا للظروف
الدعم يعني الظروف الماديه للجمعيه تم
تقليله لانه هو حاليا بيدفعوا الرسوم
رمزيه وذلك مقابل العمليات دي العمليات
الولاده والولاده القيصريه من اين ابرز
الحالات التي اتت محوله من اين طبعا اغلب
الحالات بتجي منهم درمان من الحتت المحيطه
من مدينه بده من المناطق المحيطه في كرري
او المناطق الثورات او العباسيه او كده
هناك عديد جدا من الحالات المحوله التي
استقبلناها من المستشفيات الخاصه
والمستشفيات العموميه التي كانت تعمل في
محيط القياده العامه وفي محيط المناطق
التي كانت محطه المعارك الرئيسيه في
الخرطوم فكثير جدا من الاطفال بالذات تم
تحويله من تلك المستشفيات كمستشفى السويدي
كمستشفى براعه وغيره من المستشفيات طيب
ولكن هناك عده تحذيرات مناشدات تطلق بان
الاوضاع داخل للمستشفيات هي تحتاج الى الى
تدخلات المواد المطلوبه لاجراء العمليات
وخلافه كيف هو الوضع داخل المستشفى وكيف
يمكنني ان يستمر حقيقه خلال الايام الفاتت
اللي احنا بدينا نلاحظ انه في نقص شديد
جدا في المعدات الطبيه وفي نقص في الادويه
نقص الادويه بقى اوضح في اللحظه الحاليه
انا بتكلم معاك هسه دي عندنا نقص حاد جدا
في الدريبات عند النقص الحاد جدا في
المحاليل الوريديه وفي الادويه الوريديه
انه خلال ايام القادمه انه الحكايه دي
تزيد وانه الاحتياج
بتاع المستشفيات ما يكون قادرين يعني على
تلبيتهم فدي اشكاليه حتكون مشكله كبيره في
اللحظه الحاليه انا بقدر اقول لك انه
الاسبوع اللي قدام ما حيكون فيه اشكاليه
على مستوى المعدات الطبيه لكن بعد اسبوع
متوقع انه يبدا النقص يسهر بطريقه واضحه
شكرا دكتور
اذا كانت هي صوره من داخل المستشفى هنا في
مدينه ام درمان اكثر من 300 عمليه عمليه
ولاده تمت قيصريه او ولاده طبيعيه نداء
الثقافه
لتوفير امداد لهذا لهذا المشفى يحتاج الى
محاليل يحتاج الى ادويه يحتاج الى مواد
مطلوبه
ليكون قادر على ان يستمر في ان يخدم
المرضى ويخدم كل
قاصي به يعني نحن نشكرك على تقريب الصوره
لنا للوضع الانساني خصوصا في احدى
المستشفيات ام درماننا شكرا جزيلا لك من
احدى مدن الولايه الخرطوم الثلاث جزيلا لك
الصحافه المكتب العربيه فستان شهدي
اذا من اندرمان ننتقل الى الخرطوم بحري
وينضم الينا من هناك الصحفي محمد اسحاق
عثمان محمد اهلا بك معنا في سياق هذه
التغطيه كيف هو الوضع في الخرطوم بحري
بالذات هل مازال الهدوء سيد الموقف
ان كانت الصوره التي شاهدناها الان في ام
درمان فالوضع هنا في بحري في هذه اللحظات
لا زالت الطائرات تحلق في سماء الخرطوم
بحري وتزداد وتيره هذه العمليات على ارض
الواقع ايضا اعمده الدخان ترتفع بمنطقه
معسكر المظلات بجوار جسر شامبات معلوم بان
هذه المنطقه تدور فيها عمليات او اشتباكات
قويه جدا علمنا كذلك
الاشتباكات لا زالت مستمره في منطقه
هنا في بحره ايضا
بان الجيش هذه المره قام ولا زال بمداهمه
بعض البيوت التي يختلي فيها كما علمنا عدد
من منسوبي قوات الدعم السريع تدور معارك
واشتباكات عنيفه جدا في هذا الحي بالتحديد
حي كافوري الذي يشهد اشتباكات في هذه
اللحظات وهذا هذه الاصوات التي نسمعها من
الفينه للاخرى علمنا بانها تاتينا من هناك
بصوت دوي وانفجارات في هذه المنطقه يبدو
بانها تستخدم فيها كل انواع الاسلحه من
الخفيفه والثقيله
تقول التقديرات بان هذا انعكس على وضع
المواطنين خصوصا في الحر الخرطوم بحري
سكان الخرطوم بحري محمد كانوا حذروا من
وقوع كارثه انسانيه وشيكه لماذا ما حيثيات
ذلك
نعم معلوم الناس هنا في منطقه الخرطوم
بحري يعانون من مساله انقطاع المياه وان
كانت قد بدات الان في الانفراج بعض الشيء
النسبي ولكن تعلمين بان مساله المياه
مرتبطه تماما بحياه الناس اضافه الى
الشكوى من ظاهره الجثث التي تتناثر على
ارجاء الطريق مما يسبب كارثه بيئيه واضحه
جدا معلوم بان في منطقه المجاوره لجسر في
هذه المنطقه التي شهدت عمليات عنيفه ولا
زالت تشهد عمليات لانها مجاوره لبعض
الاحياء مثل حي حله حماد
والدماجله
والمنطقه تسوق سعد قشره هذه المنطقه شهيده
اشتباكات عنيفه في الفتره الماضيه مما جعل
الوصول
لسحب هذه الجثث المطرانيه
الطريق يصبح من الامور الصعبه لوجود بعض
القناصين في اعلى البنايات في هذه المنطقه
يمتد هذا الوضع ايضا الى واحد من الشوارع
الرئيسيه شارع الشهيد بطره وشارع الانذال
هذا من الشوارع ايضا الرئيسيه التي
يرتادها الناس هذه الشوارع هذا الشارع
بالتحديد ايضا يعالج تعاني الاحياء
المجاوره له من هذه الاشكاليه بعد ان تم
مداهمه عدد من المنازل واخلاق سكان هذه
المنطقه ومن بعد ذلك تعامل معهم الجيش
اصبحت الجثث
المتراميه والمتناثره على جانبي الطريق
تسبب واحده من الكوارث هذه التي اشرت
اليها قبل قليل الكوارث البيئيه تتمثل في
هذه الجزئيه بالتحديد شكرا جزيلا لك من
الخرطوم بحري الصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه كشف سكرتير
نقابه اطباء السودان عطيه عبد الله عطيه
كشف للعربيه عن وجود اكثر من 12,000 مريض
معرضون للموت بسبب الاوضاع الصحيه مشددا
على ضروره فتح ممرات امنه لايصال المعونات
الطبيه للمتضررين
الاعداد في ازدياد شديد وهي متواليه
متوقعه بعد يعني تزايد العسكريه سوف يكون
هنالك اكثر من 12 الف مريض معرض للموت
الان نحن لدينا تقارير من ان هنالك عدد من
المرضى توفي داخل منازلهم
في المستشفيات وفي المنازل يشكل مشكله
كبيره جدا في ظل عدم وصول هذه المعينات
سوف يتعرض 12 الف للموت نحن قلناها
وقررناها ان طرفي الصراع في السودان تركوا
الشعب السوداني امام خيارين اما الموت
بالرصاص او الموت بالمرض فلول البسيطه فقط
فتح ممرات امنه بالتاكيد سوف نصل الى هذه
المستشفيات سوف يستطيع الداعمين الوصول
وتوصيل معيناتهم بالتاكيد سوف يعني يتكاتف
الجميع في في هذه الازمه
يبدو ان الاوضاع باتت ماساويه في دارفور
التي تعاني بالاساس حيث اكد مدير جمعيه
هلال الاحمر السوداني في غرب دارفوره ابو
بكر محمد اكد للعربيه على ان كل
المستشفيات غرب دارفور خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب تدهور الوضع الامني واستمرار الحرب
وقال ان كل البنى التحتيه الصحيه بمدينه
الجنينه باتت منهاره
جدا جدا
ادى الى تدمير كامل البنيه التحتيه
للمؤسسات بالاضافه لنظام الصحي بتاعه
الولايه بشكل كامل الان كل المستشفيات
خارج الخدمه هذا باب المستشفيات
بكفاءه ضعيفه جدا جدا فقط في الخيارات
بتاعه الخدمات
كل المخازن الموجوده تم نهبها تماما ما في
اي خدمات موجوده بتاعه الخدمات الصحيه
تماما اله
لال الان يعمل
بصوره جيده
منذ
خمس ايام بدانا بنخذ
من منا
طق من جانبيه حذر مبعوث الامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه لدى وصوله الى السودان
حذر من تدهور الاوضاع الانسانيه جراء
المواجهات المستمره بين الجيش ودعم السريع
جرافيت اكد التزام المنظمه الامميه اتجاه
الشعب السوداني الذي قال انه يمر بظروف
صعبه مشيرا الى ان المجتمع الدولي
والمتطوعين المحليين يبذلون قصار جهدهم
للمساعده في تحسين الظروف التي يمر بها
السودانيون
نذهب الى بورد سودان ومعنا من هناك مراسل
عربيه نزار البقدونس معنا في سياق هذه
النشره نتمنى ان تقرب لنا الصوره اكثر كيف
يبدو الوضع في بورتسودان بالتحديد حيث
تتوافد الاعداد لاملا في اللجوء
نعم في هذه النافذه وهذا المباشر سنحاول
ان نركز على الوضع الانساني والمجتمعي لكل
من قدم الى بورت سودان في ظل الظروف
الامنيه خلال الساعات الماضيه والايام
الماضيه نحن الان نتحدث في هذا المباشر من
حي هدل وهو احد الاحياء بمدينه بورسودان
من داخل هذه الغرفه بمدرسه القابلات التي
تحولت الى مركز ياوي الضيوف هذه الولايه
احد الذين قدموا من بورسودان يحكي كيف وصل
وكيف اهتدى الى هذا المركز الذي يقدم
خدمات اجتماعيه لكل من قدم الى هذه
المنطقه مرحبا بكم مرحبا بالحدث ومرحب او
ابننا نزار وكل الطاقم وجزاكم الله عنا كل
خير
عبد الرحمن السيد ادريس من قاطني الثوره
الحاره العاشره او تحركنا يوم الخميس
من العاشره ببصات الى عطبره ومن عبره
استقلنا البسط الى بورسودان وصلنا الى
الخميس والمساء كيف الوضع الان هنا في هذا
المركز الذي يقدم دعم وسنه شعبي من ابناء
بورسودان وابناء الحي لكل الضيوف الذين
وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه والله انا اشيد
اشاده كامله
بالشباب وبالشيوخ يعني تفانوا في خدمه
النزلاء
باياهم ايواهم ايواء كامل يعني كامل بمعنى
الكلمه يعني يعني من ناحيه الاكل والشرب
والعلاج وكل كل شيء يعني واستقبال طيب
يليق بالاسر السودانيه يعني
شكرا جزيلا سنحاول ان ننتقل الى جانب اخر
لنقدم ايضا اضاءه ونقدم صوره لواقع الامر
هذا التجمع الذي تشاهدونه الان هو
لابناء هذا الحي الذين يتشاورون في كيفيه
مواصله هذا السند وهذا الدعم
اداريه بهذه المنطقه وهي ام رؤوف تقدم
ايضا دعمها وهي احدى القائمات على امر هذه
المدرسه مدرسه القابلات وامي كيف الحال
اهلا وسهلا كيف تحولت تحول المركز لمركزي
يقدم خدماته لكل ضيوف الولايه المدرسه دي
اول كانت مهجوره لها سنتين دون سنحي
كانت مهجوره نظفوها
وطلبوا الدعم من الناس الحي بذاتهم جابوا
الحاجات هنا فطور غدا عشا ناس السوق
بيجيبوا اللبن بيجيبوا الرز بيجيبوا العدس
ما في حاجه ناقصان هنا نحن بواجبنا
والحريم اللي حوالين المركز بيجوا ياخدوا
معانا زايد النسوان اللي قاعدين هنا كل
واحده بتجعل
بتطبخ تطبخ ونجي نوزع للناس القاعدين هنا
لكن
التوزيع بعد نوزعه بنوزعه وعندنا ناموسيات
نحن وزعناه وفي ناموسيات جاب لنا عبد
الرحمن بلال برده ايوه جهدي شعبي لكن ما
جايانا من الحكومه ولا لكن في ناس مفترين
لكن
انا اذكرهم ناس الثوره وناس شباب على
الحمد لله نشير ايضا بان عدد من الاسر
الان وصلت الى هذا المركز تقدم الخدمات
يقدم الدعم ويقدم السند هنالك وجبات طعام
لثلاث مرات تقدم في اليوم نحو سبعين فرد
وصل الى هذه المنطقه وصل الى هذا المركز
الذي اصبح مركزا لاستقبال ضيوف ولايه
البحر الاحمر من جنسيات مختلفه من سوريا
من اليمن من السودان حتى من قدم من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم سنقترب اكثر من
المركز الذي يعاد فيه الطعام
لضيوف هذا المركز هذه هي غرفه العمليات
لصناعه الطعام هنا يقدم ويصنع الطعام
للضيوف على مدار اليوم تجتهد النسوه يجتهد
شباب الحي الشابات الحي في تقديم الدعم في
تقديم الجهد الاكل والطعام ياتي من مختلف
البيوت المحيطه بهذا
المركز احد ايضا القائمين على هذا الامر
سيوضح اكثر
كيف يستمر وكيف يمضي هذا الدعم هل من جهد
اخر رسمي ام هو فقط من جهد ابناء هذا الحي
والله يا جهادي داء من ابناء الحي من
الثورات وهذل والبيوتات القريبه وجمنا في
سوق بتاع هذا كلهم بيتعاونوا معانا ان
احنا جبنا لهم بوتاجاز وتلاجه وبتاع على
اساس انه
نعم نعم
وما في حاجه تجينا من برا كلنا برضو انه
موجود الان في عدد من الاحياء موجود طبعا
عدد من الاحيان موجود في حتات برضو فتحوها
في حداد كثيره يعني في حته اسمها ثنائيات
ومركز ثاني في داخليه بتاعه البنات هنا
وحدات كثيره يعني هذه هي الصوره المجتمعيه
لواقع مئات من الاسر التي
اضطرتها لان تكون هنا في مدينه بورسودان
هنالك من يحاول ان يغادر هذه المدينه الى
خارج السودان هنالك من يحاول ان يستقر في
هذه المدينه حتى تهدا الامور في العاصمه
وفي عدد من الولايات وبعدها يعودون الى
بيوتهم الى مساكنهم هذا هو الملمح وهذه هي
الصوره الخاصه والحصريه وهذه هي الصوره
بكل ما تحمل من معاني ومن تعبيرات وكل ما
نقلت لنا ابلغ تعبير للمشهد من حيث انتم
نزار بقداوي من بورتسودان شكرا لك
هذا واظهرت صور في نيال عاصمه جنوب دارفور
احتراق اكبر سوق للبقوليات جراء سقوط
قذائف متبادله من طرفي الصراع ما تسبب في
خسائر كبيره بالاسواق التجاريه بالاقليم
الجريمه دي فيها 85 دكان شاغل
مع ذلك مع الناس الضيوف معنا الضيوف برضو
يغدر بحوالي كم واربعين نفر دي كلها عندهم
فضائح رقدت في هذه المحل والله الغزال
تقدر زي خمسه الف شمال
وثلاثه الف جوال فول مصري
و200 جوال عدسيه
ما شاء الله الله
ومن اقليم دارفوره والصحفي صالح ابو علامه
صالح اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه اي
المناطق في اقليم دارفور التي تتركز فيها
اشتباكات الان
نعمل
نحو التهدئه في عده مدن من دارفور كما ان
هنالك حركه للنزوح داخل المولود دارفوريه
للمناطق الاكثر امانا رصدنا يوم امس حركه
من مدينه نيالا الى مدينه الضعين عاصمه
دارفور باعتبارها ولايه ايضا اكثر امنا
عدد من الاسر سافروا الى الفرق دارفور
بهدف الاستقرار هناك حتى
ايام الحرب هذه نعلم ان في جنوب دارفور
لجهودنا بين الجيش في الدعم السريع ولكن
هذه المدنه حجره نسبه لسماع
المتفلثين بعدد من المحلات التجاريه لكن
مع هذه الاشياء تسعى المبادرات الاهليه
وتسعى ايضا الجهود الرسميه لحسمها
الفترات القادمه
اكثر بقعه
توتر هذه الايام مدينه الجنينه تم توقيع
الوثيقه لوقف العدائيات بين المجموعات
المتحاربه في الجنينه ولكن الهدوء الحضري
يسود الجنينه خاصه وان هنالك اطلاق للعينه
الناريه هنالك خرق للهدنه
وايضا هنالك بعض الغماصه ما زالوا منتشرين
في الاحياء يهددون
الحركه يهددون حركه يعني صالح اتفاق وقف
اطلاق نار وقف العنف الجنينه لم يترجم على
ارض الواقع 100%
نعم الترجمه بطيئه لهذا الاتفاق حتى الان
في هذه اللحظات قوات الدعم السريع وسلطه
الاحتياطي المركزي تنزل الى سوق الجنينه
بهدف فتح الطرقات وتامين ما تبقى من
الجنينه نعلم بان المعرفه التي دارت تاثر
منها سوق كثيرا وتم نهب معظم
المحرك هنالك
سرقه مستمره لما تبقى من السوق الان قوات
الاحتياط المركزي ومعها الدعم السريع في
سوق الجنينه بهدف تامين السوق وايضا يجب
كما نص الوثيقه يجب فتح الطرقات المؤديه
الى السوق المؤديه هي الاحياء حتى تستطيع
طرق الانجاز يستطيع الهلال الاحمر
حركه احيائي لرفع الجثث ايضا حتى يستطيع
الجرحى الوصول الى المدارس التي تم فيها
الان فتح مراكز علاجيه لتلقها لزعافات
الاوليه ولتل ايضا العلاجات الاوليه
للجروح هنالك عدد كبير من الجرحى في مدينه
لا يوجد مكان لعلاجهم حتى هذه
يموت بسبب
تدم وجود دم عدم وجود
ادري هي منجزه للحياه في مدينه حتى هذه
اللحظه هنالك غياب للمساعدات الانسانيه
ولا توجد منظمات تتدخل
[موسيقى]
لترعى عن عدد كبير من النازحين وعدد كبير
ايضا من المتاثرين بهذا الصراع طيب بالنظر
الى خصوصيه اقليم دارفور ما الذي يخشى منه
اليوم من وقوعه في دارفور في حال طالت
الازمه واحتدت المعارك اكثر
في حاله طالت الازمه وفي حاله
طالت ايضا المده
المتعلقه او مده السيوله الامنيه هذه اذا
استمرت دارفور منطقه هسه تحتاج الى امن
متماسك تحتاج الى قوات تخمد النيران كل ما
تشتعل اذا استمرت الامور بهذه الطريقه
حتما ستكون التفلتات كثيره
وتندلق البلاد الى ما يخشاه الجميع هو
الحرب الاهليه هنالك اماكن يمكن ان نسميها
قنابل موته في دارفور خاصه وان هنالك
صراعات تاريخيه بين القبائل ليست القبائل
العربيه والقبائل الافريقيه فقط وانما
الصراع ايضا هنالك قبائل عربيه مع بعضها
البعض بعض الاماكن لذا
التامين دارفور وايضا عدم امتلات الاوضاع
في دارفور هو الضامن الوحيد لعدم الانزلاق
الى حروب اهليه في فنلندارفور شكرا جزيلا
لك من اقليم دارفوره الصحفي صالح ابو
علامه
وفي محاوله لتخفيف اعباء القتال الداخلي
بين قوات الجيش ودعم السريع الذي يدور في
السودان منذ اكثر من اسبوعين يخاطر مستشفى
خاص في ام درمان بفتح ابوابه لخدمه النساء
الحوامل واجراء ولاده دون مقابل الماده
وفي ظل ظروف الامنيه وانسانيه توصف
بالكارثيه
تردي المؤسسات الصحيه
[موسيقى]
يرافق استمرار القتال في السودان
لكن مستشفى خاصا في ام درمان
ينجح بفتح ابوابه لخدمه النساء الحوامل
مجانا
في ظل نادى من شبه كامل للامن
وارتفاع اثمان المستلزمات في السوق
السوداء
اكثر من عشره اضعاف السعر الحقيقي
320 عمليه ولاده قيصريه اجراها منذ اندلاع
القتال
فيما تقول نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان
اكثر من خمسين مستشفى بالخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل
وتحذيراته من انهيار القطع الصحي تتواصل
اكد مندوب السعوديه الدائم لدى منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي اكد ان المملكه تبذل
جهودا حثيثه لحل الازمه السودانيه وانهاء
الصراع وطالب خلال اجتماع منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي طالب الاطراف السودانيه بوقف
كافه اشكال التصعيد لافتا الى مواصله
القيام بدور الانسان ودبلوماسي كبير في
الازمه كما شدد على تطلع بلاده لوقف دائما
لاقتتال في السودان وانخراط الاطراف في
حوار من اجل السلام هذا ودعا مندوب
السعوديه الاحترام كافه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه بالسودان والعمل على حمايتها
[موسيقى]
الطوارئ
طبعا كل المراكز المعطله بحاجه الحرب
[موسيقى]
نعمل في هذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم
امكانيات اللي ما موجوده
سحق بعض الادويه والمعدات
في هذه الاثناء
ان اسعار السلع الاساسيه من الوقود الى
المواد الغذائيه والمياه المعبئه ارتفعت
بنسبه 40 الى 60% واكثر في بعض المناطق
وافاد برنامج الاغذيه العالمي بان نحو ثلث
السكان البالغ عددهم اكثر من 46 مليون شخص
كانوا يعانون من الجوع قبل اندلاع الصراع
مشيرا الى ان العنف يمكن ان يغرق ملايين
الاشخاص في الجوع
تتفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه كلما فشلت الهدن
المتتاليه حيث يامل السودانيون في وقف
دائما لاطلاق النار لتسهيل المهمه لفتح
ممرات الانسانيه عاجله لمساعده الاهالي
مقترح هدنه وموافقه ثنائيه وعهود
بالالتزام ومن ثم ترحيب دولي سيناريو
متطابق تكرر 6 مرات على مدار اسبوعين في
السودان دائما ما ينتهي بالطريقه ذاتها
دون اي نتائج مرجوه مع تبادل طرفي الصراع
الاتهامات بخرقها
اولى المحاولات كانت يوم الثامن عشر من
ابريل لمده 24 ساعه ليتم خرقها باشتباكات
في الخرطوم وهي وليده ساعات اما الثانيه
هدنه قصيره المدى لمده 24 ساعه انتهت قبل
ان تبدا بالطريقه ذاتها التي انتهت فيها
الاولى
هي اول هدنه تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال ايام
عيد الفطر او كما يفترض ذلك انتهت
باشتباكات متفرقه
تمديد للسابقه لمده 72 ساعه في يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسابع والعشرين من
ابريل تم تابع ببساطه امريكيه لكن
الانفجارات والاشتباكات استمرت خلالهما
واجهت مصاعب قبل تطبيقها حتى فالاشتباكات
كانت تدور جنوبي الخرطوم مع تحليق لسلاح
الجو السوداني ورد مضادات الطائرات من
قوات الدعم السريع
خروق كانت بشكل اساسي في نقاط حساسه مثل
محيط القياده العامه في الخرطوم والقصر
الرئاسي بالاضافه الى اندرمان وبحري
واقليم دارفور
لا تبصر النور لم تكن اي منها مفتاحا لفتح
باب المفاوضات ووقف القتال في البلاد ولم
تنجح اي منها حتى في السماح بفتح ممرات
انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي باوضاعهم
المترديه اذا عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات